hey this next clip is fascinating
because we've been talking about does
Trump privately believe all of the
nonsense lies that he tells so as an
example we were told that Trump was
privately repeating that three to five
million people voted illegally for
Hillary Clinton long after his bogus
election integrity commission had been
disbanded without finding any evidence
of three to five million illegal votes
for Hillary he seems to truly believe
that three to five million people voted
illegally for Hillary Clinton
inauguration crowds long after the
inauguration crowd stuff was out of the
news I believe we also heard that Trump
was privately talking about it so maybe
he genuinely believes whatever lie about
his inauguration crowd cut to last week
last week Donald Trump referred to Apple
CEO Tim Cook as Tim Apple it's on video
just a reminder so we all have it
present in our minds I mean you've
really put a big investment in our
country we appreciate it very much Tim
Apple I mean you've really put a big
investment in our country we appreciate
it very much Tim Apple so it's it's like
super crystal clear that he called him
Tim Apple there there's now a new report
from Jonathan Swan at Axios which is
reporting that at mar-a-lago a few days
ago Donald from told Republican donors
at a private meeting that what you just
saw on video never happened
Trump calling Tim Cook Tim Apple is on
video but Trump told Republicans in the
room that it's quote fake news and that
what he said was Tim Cook Apple really
fast and so someone has deliberately
misreported it as Tim Apple but he
actually said Tim Cook Apple to donors
who were in the room talked to the
reporter from Axios Jonathan Swan and
they say we can't understand why Trump
is lying about something that's on video
and the most interesting thing is that
the donors said they don't even care
about it and this is the exact type of
thing Pat that we were talking about
with doctor Gartner earlier which is
Trump called someone the wrong name his
supporters don't even really care about
that
many of them have already forgotten
about it why is he in a private room of
donors even bringing it up and this is
sort of a trademark of Trump lying about
things that don't really matter or are
undeniable because they're on video and
he's done it before with the Access
Hollywood grab him by the [ __ ] video
initially Trump said the video was fake
that it wasn't his voice on the video he
later admitted it was his voice but it
was just locker room talk and this is
you know Pat I know people will get mad
about what dr. John Gartner said about
Trump's cognitive decline and and sort
of state mental state this is exactly
the behavior that people are talking
about well Trump does need to learn how
to pick his battles that's true
we speculate that maybe him calling Tim
Cook Tim Apple has to do with some sort
of cognitive decline but it may not be
that you know he may have just slipped
up it's kind of similar to when Obama
said that he had visited 57 states but
of course there are only 50 it could
have just been a misspeak but leave it
at that everyone does that everyone
makes mistakes like that you don't have
to revisit it you don't have to reopen
this chapter just move along yeah no one
cares in terms of his base and it is
part of a broader pattern as dr. John
Gartner pointed out but even still
denying that it happened just doesn't
make any sense and there's a few
possibilities trunk may be the type of
liar who lies so much that he thinks
he's an incredibly good liar and that
he'll be able to convince people like
Trump might actually think yeah I know
it's on video but if I just tell them
it's it's fake and that's not what I
said I can convince them because I'm
just that compelling the other
possibility is Trump has actually
convinced himself that it never happened
and as I asked dr. John Gartner earlier
both are concerning it's not clear which
is more disturbing but in total it ends
up being shameless gaslighting combined
with the weaponized narcissism that
we've sort of come to take for granted
from Donald Trump over his couple of
years as president of the United States
very bizarre stuff and the Republican
donors don't even care